the beijing games set to start in just a
few days but not far from there the
horrors of china's human rights abuses
continue to unfold more than a million
religious minorities mothers fathers
brothers and sisters locked away in
prison camps there their children
certainly not spared sent to orphanages
many placed in boarding schools to make
them loyal to the communist regime
to say it's unspeakable would not be
doing it justice in fact the real issue
lies in who is listening or choosing to
do anything about it olympic sponsors
lying low claiming they had no choice in
the venue and calls for a boycott brush
brushed aside our next guest knows this
all too well roushana boss is the
founder and executive director of the
campaign for uyghurs her sister a
retired doctor
was taken more than three years ago
in retaliation
for speaking out against genocide sadly
she is not the only loved one to vanish
welcome and thank you so much roshan for
joining us and telling us your story
your sister and dr gulshan abbas a
retired medical doctor was taken and
secretly imprisoned we're told by the
ccp in 2018
why did they take her
thank you sandra
i spoke
about the genocidal policies
on chinese government that's conducting
against my people
using my
freedom of expression but i am doing
today my advocacy work and speaking
against those genocidal gains china's
genocidal crimes at the cost of my own
sister's freedom
in september 2018
my sister dr guljan abbas was a retired
medical doctor was taken by the chinese
regime just six days after i talked
about those crimes at one of the think
tanks in washington dc
for months and months we had no
information on her whereabouts but only
december 2020
we learned that she was secretly
sentenced on false charges
basically designed to give the regime
impunity in
a punishing innocent oil people so it
has been more than 42 months now
i have no information on her whereabouts
she's 59 years old
when i think about her i think about
how she has been treated and if she's
safe
and i pray that she is well
and we are talking about the olympic
snacks sweet
thing is that the international olympic
committee will not guarantee for no
forced labor is involved with its supply
chains so that makes me really
frustrated because
there's these prestigious games the
olympic games could be stained with the
slave labor of my people it could even
have my own sisters for slaver these
millions of organ slaves used to produce
the goods for beijing
and is my own sister gurshan abbas is
making uniforms or the souvenirs for the
olympics
so sorry to hear that i know you've also
told us she's been sentenced you've been
told to 20 years in prison there that is
why you have written impending op-ed a
moral imperative we must lead a boycott
of the winter games what is your message
to those
who know this is happening the genocide
of millions of uyghurs and other muslims
because of their their religion and
their race and they continue on with
what some are saying simply a diplomatic
boycott of the olympics but not an
all-out boycott
yeah a diplomatic boycott is just a bare
minimum
and it has allowed a few other nations
the opportunity to firmly stand on the
correct side of the history more nations
need to join the coalition and they sent
a unified message to this genocidal
regime that we have learned from the
mistakes of our past and the aim not to
repeat them in our future but because
when you look at it there are hunting
parallels between
the berlin 36 and the beijing games that
are just
happening in a few days now
the specter of genocide hangs over these
games
as it happened in germany during the
holocaust and now it's happening in my
country
by allowing china to host the olympic
games international olympic committee
basically has condemned
millions of older people and tibetans
and hong kongers southern mongolians and
the more by refusing to respect
basic human dignity
today the conscience of the world and
humanity are being pestered and those
olympic sponsors and the nba news
which is planning to broadcast those
genocidal games and the international
committee
are failing that past
well i know you haven't heard from her
since she was taken and imprisoned your
sister we've been showing pictures of
you and your sister together there on
that screen
we wish the best for you and your family
and thank you for sharing your story
here with us
uh rushawn keep us posted and our best
to you thank you
thank you sandra okay hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else